so when someone hits you up and says
simon i've i hear everything you're
saying you make a lot of sense
but i've been on a low carb diet or i've
been on a keto diet and i'm having great
results i feel great i've lost a bunch
of weight
what is your response to that
low low carb
versus high carb from a weight loss
point of view
there
is a plethora of studies that have
essentially shown there is no
significant benefit to either
and
uh
some of the the probably the best design
studies come from professor chris
christopher gardner out of stanford
there was a very interesting finding
though rich from this study and that was
that
within the groups so within the low carb
and within the high carb
some people did really well and some
people did really poorly so there was
this sort of
wide variation so we're left in this
position today
where that is largely unanswered
there for some reason some people do
better on high carb and there's certain
people that are doing better on low carb
and
perhaps future research will will tease
out why that is
but at this stage you know i've kind of
changed my view a little bit i'd have to
say
on on low carb and i've softened i think
i've softened my approach a bit if if
that works for someone then you know i
think
that meeting them where they are is is
the better approach
and that's not to say you can't do a
low-carb diet in a healthy way right i
mean it's a it's what kind of low-carb
if you're doing a low-carb diet that's
rife with saturated fat and all these
other things that we've been talking
about not so good but there are ways of
doing it
in a healthy manner yeah so you can
you know going back to that theme the
plant predominant theme you can do a
low-carb diet within that theme
and instead of loading up on the the red
meats and and the dairy you're going to
be more emphasizing the the nuts and the
seeds and and the plant protein
and
uh you know i've
since writing this book and i uh i'm not
sure exactly
what communities have been speaking
about the book but i've had a number of
people from the low-carb community get
in contact with me and what i've uh
realized rich is
there are a lot of people in the
low-carb community
who
despite what
paul saladino and sean baker
might be saying about cholesterol
there are a lot of people who do believe
the science low carbs working for them
they're losing weight but they do
believe the science when it comes to
heart disease and they are fearful you
know these are
young parents people 40s and 50s who
you know they they they found a way of
eating that does help them lose weight
but at the same time they go to their
doctor and their doctors
their doctors like what are you doing
you know we need to put you on a statin
and
uh you know that's scary so
what i found is that there are a large
number of people who are really
receptive to this idea of you know hang
on you don't have to
abandon this approach that's working for
you you can actually do it in a way that
is evidence-based we can
you know keep you on this path of weight
loss if that's right for you
and at the same time we can modify the
foods that are that are in that diet in
a way that will drive your cholesterol
levels down drive your uh
insulin resistance down and overall
you know not just deliver on weight loss
but also put you at lower risk of of
these diseases and what would some of
those cornerstone foods be
so it's it's all about driving the
saturated fat down and increasing
polyunsaturated fats uh you're you're
trying to cut back on on meats and dairy
in particular and you're you're wanting
to increase
nuts and seeds and and seafood if you
eat seafood um is a much better source
of
polyunsaturated fats much lower in
saturated fats compared to
two meat
so those are the main
little tweaks but also finding ways
within their their diet
to
increase fiber as well is important uh
and you can do that through
in a low-carb manner where instead of it
being you know leaning heavily on the
sort of starchy foods you're really
trying to increase the volume
of uh sort of low low calorie very
nutrient dense vegetables right like
super low glycemic vegetables
[Music]
you